for Democrats it's a showdown in the
American heartland the fourth
presidential debate analysts say marks a
contest between the Democratic Party's
extremes I believe it will be a faceoff
as we are looking at public opinion
polls we're saying that they're
essentially tied and it's looking more
and more like a race between bottom or
on one end of the party spectrum the
establishment candidate former Vice
President Joe Biden on the other the
progressive Massachusetts senator and
the new frontrunner Elizabeth Warren so
who do you like I like Biden and why
because I think he'll settle things down
and get things on an even keel he'll
work with the other side and get things
done I think Elizabeth Warren can beat
him I do I think because she always is
on point she has plans she has you know
policy she doesn't get up there and get
into like argument with them but with a
dozen candidates spanning the same stage
it's also the largest debate yet one
that offers the prospect of a breakout
moment for any of them you forgetting
what you said Maddox we be in for what
you said just two minutes ago
it will be the site of many firsts the
first debate since impeachment
proceedings for President Trump and
every candidate on the dais wants him
impeached there are many many of us
upstairs right now making signs to
support Donald Trump tomorrow for Bernie
Sanders the first debate since he was
sidelined by a heart attack for Joe
Biden the man with the most to lose the
first debate since President Trump asked
Ukraine to investigate him for Elizabeth
Warren the first debate since surging
polls have made her the front-runner in
this race the Democratic Party picked
Ohio for good reason it's known as the
bellwether state in 30 of the 32 past
elections of the candidate who won here
won the presidency the latest was Donald
Trump this time the Democrats want to
deny him this trend-setting State for
second tier candidates this is a chance
to rise to the top tier in post-debate
polls it's gonna narrow it's already
been narrowing so we'll see how many
call it quits qualifying for the next
round will be harder so for the other
candidate failing to gain traction here
could make Ohio the end of the campaign
trail John Hendricks
al Jazeera Westerville Ohio